seit märz 2013 beteiligt sich das
österreichische bundesheer an der
european junior training mission in mali
derzeit stellt das bundesheer neben dem
kommandanten auch den chief instructor
und mehrere trainer die meisten davon
sind soldaten des jagdkommandos
oberstleutnant erwin gartler koordiniert
derzeit in der funktion des chief
instructor über 100 trainer aus 20
nationen
unsere hauptaufgabe ist hier die
ausbildung der malische streckenrechte
diese reicht von der praktischen
ausbildung über geräte konnte bis zur
theoretischen unterrichten in dem er
auch das internationale humanitäre recht
integriert ist von 20 13 bis jetzt hat
sich im bereich der ausbildung aber
einiges getan als ich 13 führten die
trainer noch die basisausbildung
einer der trainer ist der gebürtige
burgenländer markus der unteroffizier
ist seit sechs monaten im einsatz heute
gibt er einige einblicke in die
ausbildung am übungsplatz
heute wird die sichere fortbewegung im
konvoi mit dem gefecht fahrzeug puma
trainiert das schwergewicht der
ausbildung ist dabei das richtige
verhalten bei hinterhalten und
sprengfallen
und so schnell wie möglich zu dem
fahrzeug sich vor arbeiten damit sie
eben die verwundeten
behandlung kenner
die aktion da heraus und ist jetzt
vorbei wir machen jetzt die
nachbesprechung sonne was gut war und
was verbessern müssen
stage elend trotz der hitze ist die
motivation einmal toppen sehr hoch zu
setzen das gelernte
neben der hitze stellt aber auch die
koordinierung von 20 nationen eine
herausforderung dar sowohl die
österreichische als auch die
internationalen trainer schätzen diese
zusammenarbeit auf einen
ein vorteil ist sicher dass wir auch in
europa
hier besonders mit unserem
österreichischen kriterien als
partnerschaft das erleichtert die arbeit
der mehrwert für uns ergibt sich aus dem
erfahrungsaustausch zwischen den
instruktoren daher verschiedenste
erfahrungswerte und wissen aus anderen
einsätzen vorhanden sind